Oh, do I just start whenever?
Okay, uh, I feel like initially it was pretty, uh, simple, everything came naturally to me,
but during this part, the double, oh, sorry, am I on the pause? The, this one, for me, it was a
particularly, like, flowy movement, so that one was, um, the, the most, uh, how do you say it,
like, enjoyable for me to do throughout the whole process, and I feel like, uh, after the double
knife hand down, that's when things start to get a little bit complicated, so that's when I started
paying more attention to my movements, and that potentially brought me out of the zone, because
I was being a lot more analytical with what I need to do next, and, uh, yeah, and how to make
sure it looks good. This one, this one particularly, um, I had to make sure I was counting for, uh,
the appropriate amount of time.
So that's when I, uh, that, that brought me a lot into reality, because, uh, the movements before
that were a lot more flowy. I was able to just naturally put them out, um, yeah, but this one,
I had to actually concentrate on how long I was doing it for.
Starting here, uh, everything was a little better, but once I got to the side,
I started to work on my hands, and I was able to do a lot of things.
I had to worry about, um, distance, because I was getting quite close to the wall, so that, uh,
potentially, like, distracted me a little bit from my movements.
And for me, this movement was the hardest, so I had to really concentrate on where my hand placement
was, and how, when I have to draw my hand back, or the strength that I have to put it back out.
Everything from here on was very natural, and it just flowed out, uh, naturally for me.
so as you can see your pattern is scored based on the number 10 so out of 10 is your is your one
as you can see it's split up into two parts we have our accuracy and our presentation of this
so we'll start off with the accuracy first so your accuracy it's actually scored from
a four so from the number four you're actually marked during your presentation of your pattern
and then with that one any mistakes that you make whether if it's a minor mistake you get a minus
of a 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys know about the
difference between the two so with a minor mistake it's a very very small thing so say
we're doing a
out of block if it's not your shoulder height maybe it's a little bit lower or maybe it's a
tiny bit higher that's a minor mistake so that's a 0.1 a major mistake would be you're supposed to
do an out of block in the pattern but you forget and you say you do a rich hand strike instead
so that would be a major mistake so with a minor mistake uh let's say pattern one for example
there's 20 steps it's not uncommon to have up to maybe 14 15 mistakes
in the pattern so if you're doing a out of block in the pattern you're supposed to do a
20 patterns uh sorry the 20 steps so the reason for that one being uh it needs to